this is
the ramsay show you can be intentional
about your character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studio this
is the ramsey show it's where america
hangs out to have a conversation about
life
i'm ken coleman joined by my colleague
dr john delony
we are ramsay personalities and we each
host shows on
the ramsey network and so we are here
with you this hour
to take your calls triple eight eight
two five
five two two five it is a free call
triple eight eight two five
five two two five dr john delaney will
take calls
on your mental emotional health
relationships we'll talk about
ugly work stuff because that's what i
talk about
uh and we'll take your career questions
your work questions hey ken i'm on the
ladder i want to get
up the ladder i want to get promoted i
need to get started in something else
whatever it is and of course we're gonna
take your money questions
and john and i love to be together doc
always good to be on the big show with
you man it's good to see you i haven't
seen you for
yeah about 12 hours i know we're fresh
off a wonderful time
uh in dallas texas with andre leadership
summit it's always fun too to be in a
room
2500 leaders that was fun fired up to
get better and entree throws a party yes
they do
so so much fun triple eight eight two
five
five two two five is the number let's
get it started with crystal
in las vegas nevada crystal how can we
help
hi thanks for having me on
well one of the issues i have is that
i've been at a company for like
two years and i'm not really getting
promoted in my career
and i want to move to another city to
get a better job but my boyfriend
doesn't want to move
and we want to get married now if i stay
in las
vegas i can't work anywhere else because
as a journalist we have these things
called non-compete
so it's either i stay here and get out
of journalism
or i move and kind of break up with him
yeah well let's talk about you for a
second well let's forget about him
i'm not real thrilled with him but we'll
get to him in a moment john i might have
doc
weighing on this from a relationship
standpoint that's his area
but i do want to get really clear on
what your dream is in this other city
and why you want to go there i want you
just tell yourself not just us why do
you want to move
forget him why do you want to move why
is it important
because i work a really tough schedule i
work like midnight to 8 a.m
wednesday through sunday and i fall
asleep in church and i
don't really have much of a outside life
out of work
so i want to find something with a
better schedule
and that i can kind of move up the
ladder away go why
why'd you get into journalism
because i feel like everyone needs to
have their story told and i wanted to be
a representative for people of color in
different communities and to make sure
that
everyone's accountable why go one level
deeper i love that answer tell me why
that's important to you
because when i was growing up in new
orleans and hurricane katrina happened i
felt as a person of color i was
personally ignored
and no one was paying attention to me
and that inspired me to perceive this
career in journalism in which i tell the
story of people
who are at the bottom and who are being
ignored in society
john that's that's a lie
that one's wired into your soul that's
from your story
so here's the deal the reason i just
walk you through that
is because you need to have that front
and center right now john's gonna walk
you through the relational piece
uh but i wanted you to hear you share
why it's so important that this this
isn't a move
just for a job this isn't a move
to make your boyfriend uncomfortable
this isn't about
you and selfishness this is about your
purpose this is about your why
you need to make the move john i think
she makes the move whether he comes or
not and if they're talking marriage
and he's not willing to make a move
because of that
why i got some real problems john help
me out i'm the same so crystal walk us
through
i'm going to call him a knucklehead and
that's a that's a that's that's my
neutral
right that's pretty gentle for me it's
right down the road in the middle of the
road for me
tell me about this knucklehead what what
a what a part about
your life mission is he not resonating
with
well i mean he's been here for a long
time like this is his um
home city so i definitely understand it
everything that he knows and loves is
here
part of me doesn't want to move either i
actually like the city it's just that
i'm not really progressing here at the
current company that i'm at
how long has you not compete for
for a year a year have you
sat down and dreamt about and i'm
wandering back into ken's world here
have you
dreamt about other ways to tell stories
of marginalized people
that it would allow you to get some
experience and some skills and then
in 366 days you slide back into this
role
yeah i thought about starting a small
small community newspaper for um
and kind of lower income area of the
city here
crystal how much money do you need to
make
not really that much it's not really
about the money
well i understand i understand it's
insanity sure you got to pay bills
though yeah we got some realities how
much money do you need to make you're
not married remember the
so this is a boyfriend he didn't put a
ring on it yet how much money do you
need to make
probably 50 000 okay i just want to be
real honest with you
uh john's asking you the right question
there might be some other ways
to get to where you want to get to
besides moving from vegas to this job
however they've got to be realistic and
you starting a community newspaper
you're not going to make 50 000.
you're gonna lose fifty thousand yeah
that is eight that is not a reality and
i don't want
to let you think that that's a reality
right
i want you to go back to the question
john yeah you didn't answer the question
you just talked about how
you understood his point of view because
he's always lived in vegas and
everything he loves
is in vegas well it's about ready to not
be the case and
if he loves you uh i want to know john
asked you a really good question
what part of that vision that you so
beautifully shared with us
does he not get excited about
he just doesn't see the need for me
to move he kind of believes that i
should be able to start my own
thing here um whether it be
like a website tv station newspaper
etc i don't think he really has a grasp
of um
yeah a reality of journalism yeah
you know he needs a grasp of two things
number one uh
how media like that actually operates
how long it takes to get up and running
how much money it spends off and oh by
the way you have to take care of
yourself you're not relying on boyfriend
i think this is a sit-down conversation
john where it's like this is my vision
now to john's point
uh i don't think you have to put all the
eggs in this basket of moving out of las
vegas however
this move to this new position
moves you up the ladder that was the
word i got most excited about ladders
what's great about ladders is as we move
up we have other options to move to
different places you could come back to
vegas
but the reality is crystal you are
capped you have a
lid on yourself your words your reality
it's a lid where you are now and if you
don't
leave soon to do what you know you're
supposed to do whether it's this
position john where she moves
out of vegas my concern is she's going
to begin to resent
the boyfriend and i see that over and
over and over where people a they don't
have the
the why conversation they don't get to
why it becomes a job i want this title
and that's not a reason to move it never
but when you're that wired into who you
are
and your mission on earth then that's a
sit-down conversation
because five years from now 10 years
from now that's when the the
the fires of resentment will burn
through that relationship and it's hard
to maintain when you have a mission
in life i'm gonna tell you this right
now i wouldn't marry anybody who wasn't
on board with what i believe god created
me to do
sorry hey don't move more ramsay show
coming right up
[Applause]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners
we're intentional about choosing the
best advertisers
to recommend blinds.com is no exception
they offer high quality window
treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering
free shipping and a guaranteed perfect
fit
go to blinds.com and take advantage of
this week's special savings
[Music]
so
[Music]
you're listening to the ramsey show i'm
ken coleman joined by my colleague dr
john deloney
as we take you through this hour triple
eight eight two five five
two two five triple eight eight two five
five two five of course we're taking
your questions about your life whether
that's money questions
whether that's relationships mental
emotional health
how about your work you want to get a
bigger shovel so you can get out of debt
faster well we'll talk about that as
well triple eight eight two five
five two two five let's go to dallas
texas
tony's on the line tony how can we help
yeah um the question i have is how does
how does a a person deal
with their spouse having cancer oh
man i'm sorry tony is that you yeah
oh man tell us about it what
um diagnosed in june of last year with
stage four breast cancer
oh wow
i'm sorry man so walk us through the
last walk us through the last year
yeah um well um
she was she she got sick not feeling
well
and she's she she's
she didn't like she's not going to the
doctor which is you know a lot of women
are like that
well me too i don't like it either yeah
finally we
finally she went to the doctor and and
uh she was
having some chest pains took her to the
doctor and uh
and they told her that she needed to see
an oncologist
so we took her to the oncologist and
they they said she had stage four breast
cancer and
metastasized oh my goodness so
um you know um how does a person deal
with working
uh and in my situation away from home
yeah
and and dealing with uh with that and
i've got
you know family issues and so forth and
how does a person deal with that the
best way to
how much time is this way to deal with
it what's that
so if you look up 10 months later what's
or 11 months later what's what's the
status of her health have they given her
um how many weeks left or months left or
years left or is this going to be a
three to five year thing
doctor she didn't say she said it was
she said it was
it was in several places and she said
she didn't uh
she did she couldn't give her didn't
tell her she could have
two months or two years she she said it
was just
and she has gone through chemo and she
went through the
hard chemo and she's been through the uh
through the
she's on the palliative stage now the or
the just
not so not so
corrosive or bad stuff well palliative
care tells me
you're getting to the end here versus
well she's
she's not she's she's actually
she's actually said she's feeling better
okay
but it's they didn't say
she hasn't uh she goes to the doctor and
she tells me that
everything's okay but so here tony
here's here's what i'm gonna do if i'm
you
okay um um this is less clinical advice
this is just
me as a guy in your neighborhood okay
i'm gonna sit down with my wife and i
wanna come to
that next doctor appointment the next
time there's there's these six month
intervals usually and and if she's in
palliative care right now they're
probably
monthly if not every other month and i
would ask
to go with her not because you don't
trust her but because
you want to hear from the doctor so that
you can understand this
right yeah they've already they've
they're they're giving her the
the the treatments every three weeks
okay so i would ask
well but there's treatments but then
there's also scans and there's updates
so treatments are just going to follow a
treatment regimen that's different than
here's an update here's where we're at
here's the numbers here's what's going
on right
i want to be i would ask my wife and
it's her right to tell you no
but i would ask my wife can i be in that
room with you can i go with you
a to support you and be so that i can
get a status up so i can hear where
we're i need to be in that room i want
to feel what's going on here
uh you're i get a sense that you think
your wife isn't being totally honest
with you or you don't know what's going
on
there's just a miscommunication here and
sometimes people
love their spouse so much
that they say i'm feeling better
and they're not telling the truth and
not to be ugly or to be a liar but to
protect and
love and what y'all need right now is a
real dose of where are we
at number so you ask how can you handle
this
there's not a way to handle this this is
the hope i should say it sucks it's the
worst thing that can happen
other than losing a child and so you
don't
and that's already happened okay so
you've been down this road
there's not a quote-unquote way to deal
with this
you hold your wife's hand and y'all walk
through this together and it's hell
and it's fire and it's terrible and you
get a group of people in your life
outside of your wife that you can trust
and go to and cry with
and say what am i supposed to do now and
who will show up at 2am with hamburgers
and tacos
and just sit with you
but trying to get a checklist of how to
now there's some basic things right or
so
can people help with the yard and we
have food and all you know all those
things you've been down here
but the temptation is to try to make
this suck less
and you really can't your wife and your
best friend
is real real sick my problem is
i work 500 miles away from where i live
and that's where the numbers are going
to be important to me
if this is my wife's got three months to
live
that job can take a hike because i'm
going to take every second
of my wife and my time left and we'll
figure that other stuff out
that's what i've been thinking and
trying to do if this is a 5 and 10 and
15 and hey things are looking up the
numbers are good and it was stage four
but we actually caught it and and and
then we're going to talk to family we're
going to have a whole different
conversation that's why
getting a true update of where your
wife's health status is
and ken if and again tony if i'm you i'm
looking for a job
closer to home absolutely are you what
happens if you walk today from this job
financially what happens i am
i'm um
i have i have virtually no debt
i own i own everything i have except for
uh i've got one vehicle that's financed
and but everything else is
do you have health insurance i have i
ever think no
uh i don't um my my
my property and all my my other vehicles
are paid off and
but my problem is i don't have any i
don't have a nest egg
right so my point is how many how many
days or weeks could you go without a
paycheck
probably a month okay so john's right
we've got
we've got a situation where i'd want to
find out from the doctor best best case
best case best guess how much time your
wife has
and you've got to you've got to look at
that and go i'm 500 miles away
i'm not seeing her as often as i need to
i've got limited time with her
however we also can't do anything that's
going to set you behind
and create financial havoc in the midst
of dealing with tremendous grief
so if it's me i'm calling everybody i
know i mean this is next level proximity
principle i'm going my wife's dying
my current job is 500 miles away i want
to be with her every day
i've got to keep working i'll do
anything i'll take a
20 pay cut 30 whatever you can do
but this is an extreme time that i don't
think you'll regret this
but you've got to bring in some income
so yes john's right i am doing
everything in my power like my life
depends on it to get a job locally
to where i'm there with my wife and i'm
one phone call away
from being next to her i think that is
your number one priority right now
so that you're around her and then to
john's point um
don't do this alone you know john i
think that even in times of
peace and calm in our lives the most
underrated question that few people use
is will you help me
yeah can you give me some help but in
times like this i find that
we've seen this in our country and
certainly around the world i think
politics goes away
i think religion goes away when there's
times of crisis i just still believe in
the human spirit that they'll step up
and go gosh we got to come around tony
yeah and it it is often incumbent on
tony to say i need some help
that's my point the question that
doesn't get asked even in good times is
will you help me
and more specific here's what i need
exactly so tony i want you to reach out
to a buddy today
i want you to take a white pad and i
want y'all to meet at a local coffee
shop today
and i want you to him to walk alongside
you as you map out here's what we need
here's a game plan for
job prospects who do we need to call
who's got food
who's going to show up at our house with
pizza this weekend and then i want you
to set up some time to go meet with your
wife and her doctor
and you get some real clear answers
about what how much time you got left
and what's next we're praying for you
brother and we love you
keep us in the loop this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk
they use the same network as the larger
providers for much less
for just 30 a month get unlimited talk
text and
six gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over seventy
dollars a month
by switching to pure top just go to
puretalk.com
and enter the promo code ramsey to save
50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john deloney blinds.com's 100
satisfaction guarantee means
even if you miss measure and i have or
picked the wrong color i'd probably do
that
they'll remake your blinds for free you
get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more
use the promo code ramsey to get the
best deal today's question john comes
from patrick in cleveland i'd love to
hear ken coleman's thoughts on the
difference between nepotism
and the proximity principles patrick
burns yeah
in both cases the end result is getting
a job due to your proximity with someone
who can get you that job but it seems
like nepotism has a negative connotation
all right uh you can weigh in on this
because you you
you got a lot of background on this i've
had this question oh you have yeah well
okay so let me first frame proximity
principle and john and i'll have some
fun teeing off on this one together
so the proximity principle came out of
the ken coleman show which is part of
the ramsey network
um where i took enough calls where i was
trying to help people realize listen
if you get around people that are doing
what you want to do
pick the career it doesn't matter
whatever it is in order to do what you
want to do
fill in the blank you got to be around
people that are doing that
and in places where that work is
happening
so it's a very simple little principle
that ended up becoming a bestselling
book but it was just advice on the radio
show
initially and so the idea here is is
that when i'm around the right people
and when i'm in the right places john
that's where opportunities come
i don't have to kick doors down that's a
romanticized
motivational poster kind of thing well
it doesn't work that much most of the
time you kick a door down you get
arrested you go to jail
yeah yeah so the idea is let's get
around people that are doing it i'm
going to be able to learn
i'm going to be able to uh get some
experience and i'm going to meet more of
the right people
when i'm in the right places and then
and then i'm going gonna i'm gonna learn
from the right people
some other places i need to get into so
that's the proximity principle so now
we're talking nepotism
yes so my take on this john is the
proximity principle
and nepotism well they're not the same
thing and nepotism sure
does have a negative connotation in the
marketplace well you got the job because
it's your daddy
you got the jobs because your uncle and
all that kind of stuff however
it doesn't always have to be negative
and we've seen that in a lot of
family-owned businesses that we at
ramsey solutions we
you know entre leadership our business
uh division
i mean overwhelmingly dealing with
family-owned businesses so i would
separate those two patrick look
getting in proximity to somebody who's
not your family
that's a different angle obviously you
have
what do you call it natural born
proximity to family
but that's not the same thing i mean
family's family and if you earn it if
it's handled correctly
and everybody's wearing their employee
hat not relationship hat in the office
then you should be able to avoid it if
you're bringing it or if said person is
bringing the heat yeah so
a hundred percent of my jobs
professional jobs since i've been out of
college
have been through a relationship right
you got to have the skills you got your
credentials you got to show up and be
excellent your work but
it's because i had one or two or five
advocates who knew me and said that guy
i'll vouch for that guy that's war i've
i've worked on a challenge behind closed
doors with that guy
how do you keep somebody from looking at
the proximity principle
and beginning to roi
human interaction you and i both know
you can smell that a mile away when
somebody comes up to ramsay solutions
and says
my dream is to be on the radio how did
you do that yeah
those conversations are one of my
favorite things because you dig into why
people want to do what they want to do
then suddenly when it shifts and it does
occasionally not always when
occasionally it shifts to
so hey i hear you got an opening could
you go over there and if i put you down
as a reference it's a really good
question right
so the proximity principle is a
principle okay
right yep the very word principle means
this is a truth this is what happens so
in order to do what you want to do be
around people they're doing it get in
places where it's happening what you
don't want to do is become an
opportunity vampire
and that's what we see people coming and
they're coming in it's all about
what can you do for me what can you do
for me connection connection connection
and they leave people they suck the
blood right out feel it
yeah it's disgusting it's gross it's
smarmy we can see those people coming to
my way
that's not what we're talking about well
we're talking about the proximity
principle is a principle but when i'm
around the right people when i'm in the
right places i must be humble
i must be humble i'm not here to prove
i'm not here to convince you that i am
god's gift for this position so there's
humility there second we want to be
hungry and saying i want to learn i'm
not here to
sway you i'm not here to get a
connection from you
i'm here to learn from you love it and
when you come in it that way right there
now the person that you are engaging
with connecting with
feels value well yeah i get the question
all the time ken i can't offer any value
to john deloney yeah you can
let me tell you how you do it you go
john i've been really impressed with
your journey
i've kind of read your story i've
watched your journey at ramsey solutions
i love what you do
i'm a clinical psychologist and i think
content may be in my future but i'm not
sure
can i ask a couple things how do you
move from this to this and they're all
questions about your perspective
and your experience on their situation
that's
insight they're not asking for a
connection they're not asking for favor
they're asking for insight
which i would call knowledge and they're
asking for wisdom maybe hey john i got a
couple things here
you're a professional experience yeah
what do you think would be the best
route
do you not feel valued of course in that
moment somebody comes and tells you
your what you're putting out in the
world is is
is good your story and your journey
is is worthy yeah it makes me feel
awesome yeah
after a week of just grinding it out and
recording and show after show and
look at it and all that someone says hey
yeah i'm watching and you yeah
that's a lot so here's what happens at
the end of that conversation folks just
to put a bow on this
so what john's talking about is right so
when i approach john that way
for insight and wisdom i can say to him
hey
what do you think are some next steps
who are some other people that you think
i should connect with
what are some places that maybe i should
get into and a place could be as general
as
a webinar online a conference a clinic
and so when i ask that of john i'm not
asking john to
network for me or do me a favor i'm
asking john for
his hey who should who are some other
right people
that i should connect with and only then
does john go here are a couple people
and oh by the way
i'll make the connection there you go
that's how that works yeah let me email
that in
that's i like that and so you can't turn
people into commodities
for connections that's why i hate the
word networking i like the word
connecting yeah because connection to me
and the way i look at it is it there's a
spirit yeah
well and i have tell me if am i wrong on
this opinion
if somebody comes in and says hey you
only got this job because you know so
and so
my impulse is to say so is that
is that a wrong impulse well i think
it's an incomplete impulse because i
think the answer that's i know
i know what your process was i didn't
know you before you came here so i've
watched this
and you didn't it wasn't just because
you knew somebody here
that was the reason you were brought to
the table right but you got hired on
your merits
there you go so i go how do you respond
you're wrong but thanks for playing
that's what i'd say such a kid call him
an answer well but that's true
it's awesome hey guess what i'm gonna
tell everybody right now i knew dave
ramsey
for 10 years before i ever worked at
i ramsey solutions solution interview
ever but i did not get the job because i
knew dave
i didn't yeah so i got the job i got the
job
because he had a position and dave said
hey
we got a position we need filled it
includes this this and this we think you
can feel it we've been talking about you
which you know if you're if you're
interested in that position it was not a
ramsey personality by the way
yep so that's garbage yeah and i would
say to them
you know it's the old you ever seen a
turtle on the top of a fence post
that turtle didn't get up there by
himself that's exactly right none of us
did right none of us
so relationships are the currency folks
connections with people are the currency
for success
you're not gonna get anywhere on your
own and good luck
you gotta show up and be ready to rock
and roll when you get there right
but again they won't carry you very we
can't be relationship vampires walking
around going hey can you introduce me to
this person
i'd be like go pound sand you didn't
even say hi to me
you didn't even ask for any advice you
just want me to open up my rolodex
that i busted my butt to create for you
go outside and dance in traffic that's
what i think about that that's crazy
but people do that yeah well and i
always
i i tell people a lot when they say hey
would you write me a recommendation
letter for this
i tell folks my son looks exactly like
me i gave him his
face and my name that's all i've got to
protect him from
and so i'm real particular about those
type of things right because it's all i
got yeah
right yeah so let's make relationships
for the sake of relationships
yes come what may yes listen if you're
great at connecting with people whether
on purpose or not good things are going
to come your way that i guarantee
all right let me tell you what else is
coming your way more
of your calls and the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
welcome back to the ramsay show i'm ken
coleman joined by my colleague dr
john delonie and we're taking your calls
triple eight eight two five five two two
five
we're talking life but before we get
back to the phones
oh my goodness uh we got an
epic two-day sale john that ends today
so i've got to tell you about it so you
can jump in on it not epic they're
giving all our stuff away
uh well you know they uh it is steeply
discounted no question
oh my goodness uh we're running this
epic two-day sale that ends today i'm
looking at this that means you can get
up to 80
off books bundles and envelopes and give
a life-changing gift i know this john
our kids need shoes they do i don't know
why if i like these prices
we have to sell a whole bunch more now
yeah we do because dave's being so
generous oh boy so hey it is springtime
that means it's graduation wedding
season so these are some great
really steeply discounted gifts and uh
so we want you to take advantage of
these sales
opportunities here's what we got
audiobooks starting at five dollars are
you kidding i was in the booth for three
days james
five dollars for three days worth of
work that's an incredible deal
the starter envelope uh for budgeting
five dollars
bundles up to eighty percent off that's
multiple books folks
and then the updated ramsay plus
marriage bundle
which now includes the new know yourself
know your money assessment use this
opportunity to give like no one else you
may change someone's life with a
very very good gift shop the epic
two-day sale
at ramseysolutions.com
store ramsey solutions dot com slash
store please buy more of mine and john's
books please we would appreciate that
uh we we just it's all going to the kids
it's all going to the kids
we won't take the time coming to me my
kids aren't getting it okay good i
appreciate that honestly i'm just
kidding
triple eight eight two five five two two
five is the number austin texas
is where we go next jay joins us there
jay how can we help
hey ken big fan i listened to your audio
book in
january and probably 200 applications
and
a couple dozen interviews later i had
two drop offers wow to go
yeah i like that story john that's not a
glamorous story that's grinding it yeah
i love that good for you jay
how can we help yeah so i'm actually a
couple hours south of austin i'm two
hours away from houston and two hours
away from austin okay
so the offer for austin is uh
it's going to be around the mid 80s plus
they're saying uncapped commission but i
have a friend that i used to work with
that works for this company and she said
it
the average is the realistic average is
more like 10 to 15 000 a year in
commission
and the position in houston is uh
it's around a 55 to 60k base and it's
it's true on cap commission i actually
so work there it's my first time out of
college
and you know i saw people make a quarter
million there after a couple years
okay um so i i have a recruiting
background i'm in sales now
and uh i'm gonna have to relocate either
way so
the the number one objective i have is
to uh
to replace my wife's income so we work
together and
once i do that it'll be in recruiting
obviously
and from there i just i can't figure out
which one i want to take go to the
company that i used to work for where i
you know
i truly could make on cap commission uh
they've already told me that they would
let me work remotely from home
until i make enough in commission to
replace your income
versus if i go to austin you know i'm
making that base right away
which would replace my life's income and
then you know from there it's just
you know how much commission can i make
yeah okay austin
austin is more expensive more expensive
yeah
yeah um especially like the
kind of north austin areas that we're
looking at way
way more expensive yeah so if i
got these numbers right your wife's
making what 15 to 20.
so i make around 58. she makes like 33
and a half
oh i see she got the combined number
okay i got you got you right right yeah
so um anytime i get a call like this on
the on the ken coleman show i
i never believe someone not because i
think you're being dishonest
but i know that there's a leader in the
clubhouse that's a golf golf
term there right there's one of these
austin or houston that's what we'll call
them
one of these is the leader in your head
uh one is in your heart
maybe there's a separation maybe it's
it's both i want to know what's the
leader right now before you call today
what's the leader can i guess before we
do this
well no because it takes away from what
i want him to do i'm trying to get him
out
i'm going to write down like oh that's
actually fun yeah so right now
i'm watching right now in studio john is
writing down show me the answer
so that we have some integrity all right
john has predicted
for you your wife's not on the phone i
can't help her
all right what's the leader me it's it's
a it's the one i know can make true and
cap commission but it's a smaller base
so it's houston yeah john wrote down
austin
i wrote down austin yeah i i can't
believe
i'm uh uh cause you're about to you're
about to take the austin job aren't you
if i get the offer yeah i'm expecting to
get it together today oh
i actually flew back from california
they they flew me there to interview me
so wait a second so wait a second wait
wait wait wait you want
you called in and and houston's leading
for you which is why you said
my answer my wife's answer john
predicted austin
maybe he knew something i didn't know
that the wife wants to go to austin
it sounds like you're not asking a job
question you're trying to get me and ken
to join your side so you can gang up on
your wife
why does your wife want to go to austin
and why do you hate me and kid
yeah i know the answer but i want you to
tell us
why she want to go to this it's actually
changed at first
her at first her choice was to take
which one makes the most money
well off the bat it's it's awesome but
down the road it's going to be houston
i know um and and then now it's changed
because she thinks that the
well and i know it too the the schools
are better in austin
it's just the area we would be in this
is a lot nicer
um but again the cost of living is so
much
higher you will eat property taxes would
almost triple yeah
yeah your cost of living evaporates any
sort of financial headway and the
reality is you're talking about mid 80s
so let's call that 85
000 is what you told us the base would
be and you've talked to a a friend
who tells you a realistic number that
you're probably capped at 15 so that's
going to put you right at 100 grand
and your cap yeah but the the good thing
is about that company though
it's a fast-growing startup out of
silicon valley and all the people that
are in leadership that i've interviewed
with
they've been promoted two or three times
within the past like three years
okay so here's where we stand i've taken
this call so many times i know you're
hysterical so here's the deal jay
there's not a right or wrong answer here
john just go hit the guy in the mouth
and be so
this is a relationship this is a
relationship decision
and houston is more money
but then austin's got all the things the
wife likes it austin's got its flair
austin's got the nice schools
all the stuff that austin has and you
can't afford
that you can't afford by the way but
that's what mama wants that's what mama
wants we used to live in houston too by
the way i know but listen forget
just for a moment would you please
forget your wife's opinion
jay just for a moment because this is
important we'll come back
what would you do forget her opinion if
she had no voice in it what would you do
go to houston i know so you guys got to
have a steak dinner
and sit down with a couple of pencils
and a pad of paper and maybe do it
together
or take two minutes before the the
appetizer comes
and write down the pros and cons of each
and let each other and then turn it into
each other john now this is
i'm not the professional relationship oh
i think you're exactly right i like them
showing each other without talking about
here's my pro con list let me read yours
and discuss it and i want to know if she
didn't like who you were at this other
company
i want to know if the part of houston
you were in
she didn't like i want to know there's
something about
the the marriage culture that was
created
you lived in houston that she's not
racing to go back
and you remember in all the good parts
and you are a hustler i can hear it in
your voice
and you're thinking 35 steps down the
road and
you just want to go where you can get
paid here's something about she didn't
like with you being
is that is that true yes or no because
we have very little time i'm not
interested in john's
no i mean her brother even lives in
houston okay so here's what i always
have a bunch of family that's so so jay
i'm gonna give you some i'm gonna give
you some cheat codes that we talk about
with video games for this dinner
all right you gotta show her come to the
dinner prepared to show her some
different areas of houston that maybe
she's not thought of that you guys can
afford to live in in two or three years
when you're making 250
or whatever you got to cast some vision
on houston
she's seeing all the things with austin
you need to your cons list needs to have
all the cost of living property taxes
all the things on it
but then your pro list for houston needs
to have we could actually afford to live
in this neighborhood schools
in this school system is one of the top
cities in america
you can find what you want to find i'd
cast a better vision for houston with
that
money and see what mama says all right i
love it fun stuff that's a relationship
issue that's not a professional
call that's that's it's uh and that's
where the astros are
dinner there you go hey i want to thank
my colleague dr john deloney beloved
astros fan i want to thank our producer
james giles our associate producer kelly
daniel
and you america thank you for listening
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show
did you know over 18 million people
listen to the ramsay show every week
and a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country
to find a station near you head to
[Music]
thermsyshow.com
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice
i am dave ramsey dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
open phones at 825-5225
as we talk about your relationships your
life your money
anything in your life we're here to walk
with you through the whole
puppy the whole burrito open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five
melissa is with us to kick off this hour
in san francisco
hi melissa how are you hi
i'm doing well how are you better than i
deserve what's up
um so i was just wondering how you
recommend um budgeting for people whose
salary or
take-home pay is pretty dependent on
bonuses
okay how long you been doing that
um i'm in my third year right now okay
you're single yeah and uh what do you
make
total so my base right now
is 95 000 and my bonus just
really depends on performance what would
you make last year
90. you made 90. i thought that was your
base
yeah that's my base and then my bonus
was 60 000.
okay so you made 150 000 last year yeah
what'd you make the year before total um
130. okay good so it's heading up then
that's good yeah i mean that means
you're performing well on this bonus
program good for you
okay well here's what um what i i've
lived on
straight commission or an irregular
income being self-employed my entire
life so i've never been able to do a
budget with a fixed
salaried income i've never been i mean i
teach people how to do it but i've never
done
one so what we have learned to do is a
prioritized
spending plan above what the known
money is now how often do you get these
bonuses
they're yearly once a year yeah
okay and so you're pretty much living on
90 and then this money comes in and you
hit the lottery
basically yeah so they just cut you a
sixty thousand dollar check one week
yeah yeah and that's a heck of a week
it's a whoo-hoo
week yeah i like it it's my favorite
week of the year
yeah okay so uh but so can and you can
run your household on 90 can't you
yeah i mean rent is super expensive
around here but
um but you're running your household on
90 aren't you
i am yeah but what i've noticed is a lot
of my co-workers they
basically go by the goal of spending all
of your base salary and then with the
bonus
they save that yeah well i don't agree
with that part but
uh but so but i i think the budget is
fairly easy we can lay your budget out
on your salary and that's your monthly
budget
and basically go on every dollar or join
ramsey plus for a free trial and get
to get the every dollar premium and
that's the world's best budgeting app
it's a very very robust
killer budgeting app to get help you
spend every dollar
of your 90 000 monthly on paper
before the month begins in the app
you're going to give every dollar an
assignment every dollar a name now then
what are we going to do with the bonus
well we're not going to uh
save that and blow everything else in in
your budget you save and operate your
household
then when you get extra money in your
case once a year you get this big budget
big bonus before the bonus comes i want
you to spend it
on paper also because a month before you
get it you know what it's going to be
don't you
so you know 30 days from now i'm going
to get 60 grand right
yeah okay so i want you to get you can
just get a yellow pad out if you want
and say i'm going to spend 60 000 here
on paper now by spending it i mean
we have to allocate for taxes if they're
not taking taxes out
we have to we're going to put some in
savings we're going to be generous with
some of it be giving
we're going to uh spend some of it on
fun
we're going to pay some debt down we're
going to hit some of the baby steps that
we've been wanting to hit
uh and some of these other things but
every dollar
always needs an assignment on any money
before it gets there now if you don't
know what the budget is or let's say
you're thinking about this in september
before you know what the number is going
to be in december
then you would start to just make a list
and say okay if i if i don't get as much
as i did last year
what's the most important thing i'm
gonna do
and you prioritize the things on this
yellow pad from most important to least
important and you go as far
down that list as the money allows you
to go
when you run out of money on that list
it should be
that you've done the most important
things to you
before you did the least important
things to you because you had a
progressively important list a list that
is listed from most important the least
important with a dollar amount beside it
how far down that list can i go and it
can be
i want to take a trip to europe and i
put a dollar amount beside it i want to
buy a car i put a dollar amount beside i
don't pay off this student loan i put a
dollar amount beside it
i want to finish up baby step three and
have an emergency fund of three to six
months
expenses and i put a dollar amount
beside it wherever you are whatever your
goals are now which one of those
is the most important is number one and
any minds left over can go to number two
and any money left over can go to number
three and it's a prioritized
spending plan now for those of you that
get have an irregular income monthly
like for instance i grew up in the real
estate business and you really do not
necessarily know what you're going to
make next month
i mean you may have some closings in the
hopper you may have some contracts that
are coming at you but you don't know
exactly what you're going to make next
month
so you really are going to live that
list out
in the coming 30 days so rent
electricity food
it starts if you're going from if you
have zero that you can count on if
you're 100 commission
like that situation yeah you'd start
with food and then you'd do utilities
and then you do food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities you know
take care of those first and then we're
going to do baby steps
and then we're going to reduce debt and
then we're going to do this and then
we're going to do that
um and you know we're not paying
property taxes before we buy food you
know we're going to decide
if i can only buy one thing what would i
buy if i could only buy one more thing
what would i buy
and you list it out like that it makes
you really prioritize your life
the psychology of getting a 60 000 check
on a friday
man you can blow that and i like the
idea of being intentional before you're
holding that money yeah you got to do it
on paper before the money comes
because it's it's gone it's just those
of us that were in the real
real estate business or other straight
commission things you know we
you know we have you know we go from uh
you know buying cadillacs to having them
towed i mean you know it's back and
forth it's all over this volatility
and uh you have this tendency in that
world not her
but if you're in that kind of a world a
sales world in particular
you have this tendency to think you can
out earn your stupidity
and i tried to out earn my stupidity for
years and i was a lot more stupid than i
was talented so
uh i couldn't do it and it kept catching
me and well even if you're not stupid
the world is still spinning around you
there's always something that wants your
money somebody else might be stupid and
cause
yeah yeah there's always something
coming at you you can just count on it
it's
just part of the dad blame equation it's
how it works
so that's a great question great
question thank you for joining us we
appreciate you being a listener
good for you killing it melissa that's
fantastic yeah that's a wonderful income
dr john deloney ramsey personality my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more
[Music]
firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr trondalone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five our question of
the day comes from
blinds.com they have a 100 satisfaction
guarantee
means even if you mismeasure you pick
the wrong color they will remake your
window blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promos they run every
month you'll save even more use the
promo code
ramsey you know sometimes i do stuff and
i go you're an idiot like when i miss
measure i screw up the line
the the window blinds and they remake
them for free even though i'm an idiot
so this is like an idiot proof guarantee
that's pretty cool
that's why they call it ramsey i'm just
kidding you gave me that one man oh
underhand pitch yeah yeah
all right all right so today's question
comes from annalee in nevada
italy writes i'm trying to get my
boyfriend and i out of debt
i only owe 28 000 in student loans
my boyfriend has almost eight times more
debt than i do but he thinks you can't
make money without spending it
how do i make him see that he's hurting
himself
run get a new point run
you can go left to california or right
to all the other states but run
you you can't um
so here's a rule of thumb when dating
do not date people you have to fix yes
or don't when you're in a relationship
and your thought is i have to
get us to that's the that's the problem
because us has to get us too
right his job is to initiate being a
grown-up
thus far he has not done that
yeah and he's not he's i mean it's not
rare that people think
you gotta spend a whole bunch of money
to make money i know that's common so
i don't want to say he's an idiot he
thinks you can't make money without
spending it right you got to spend money
to make money no he just says
you have to spend all the money you make
oh okay i always think she's in congress
no because there's been more than that
yeah there's been more than they make
yeah um apparently he does too
yeah so in what you can do in elise you
can sit down and
and show him math and you can tell him
hey look i love you and you hurt
yourself then
the the important part of that
conversation is is one that you're going
to have to decide
are you in are you out and um you can't
help him
you can't fix him you can't heal him
he's going to have to be a part of that
journey and you're going to have to
decide
do i want to walk with this guy through
his journey or not um
but you can't get you and your boyfriend
out of debt no you can only get you out
of debt and you can show him how he gets
him
out of debt so um
from a relationship perspective not a
financial perspective
um if you were my daughter and i have
grown daughters that are married
um i i would say you'd sit down with
this guy and say
uh number one cause of divorce in north
america's money fights and money
problems
the fact that we're not in agreement on
this subject is going to
end our relationship um because
i don't think i can make a life with a
guy who can't be responsible with money
and so i in order for us to go forward
i'm gonna have to see you
become responsible with money i'd be
your cheerleader
i can give you some input i can show you
some things to do
i cannot do it for you nor will i do it
for you
nor will we be together long term if you
are not engaging in
growing up and that's a conversation
from emily to her boyfriend the
conversation italy has to have with anna
lee is
i'm reading the tea leaves here but this
is somebody who struggles with
codependency this is someone who
struggles with
an identity that her value comes from
fixing other people
and i want emily to do her work on
herself
and grow her value from the inside out
let that shine to the world because it
because we need her voice out there and
then she's going to attract people who
are not projects that are not
puzzles and they're not engines who are
missing spark plugs
it's just an amazing way people attract
what they put out in the world
right let me ask you something i i don't
disagree with that uh
you know you tend to um
it's not the victim's fault that someone
is a victim but there's even been
studies shown that a rapist will pick
a the way someone walks you just feel it
yeah they're
predators they're they're a predator and
they sense weakness
and they sense the body language in
other words and so
um you know and that's what you're
saying her body languages she has this
tendency to try to fix things and so she
takes in strays kind of thing um
and let's pretend for a second that it's
not that
okay that this is and we don't know her
but but just for the sake of uh argument
with our audience because we've got a
lot of audience in their early 20s
late teens especially on youtube and
um let's pretend that this is a 19 year
old young woman
okay and um
maybe she does feel okay about herself
but she just really likes this guy
and before she know it she's kind of in
love with him and then he has this
problem
yeah and he's a great guy and except for
except for and he and this is not like
you know normally she would not be taken
in straight normally she would not be
lacking in self-esteem normally she
would not be there
but she just kind of you know this guy's
they they've built a relationship but
and then all of a sudden she realizes oh
god this guy's got issues
so i i was that's a little different
than i i'm attracting
because i i have a pattern of always you
know bringing home losers yeah i read
this quote this weekend that
i was sitting on my front porch reading
dave and i stopped
and it said sometimes you have to have
the courage to break your own heart
because it's the right thing to do
and sometimes you've got to do something
so hard that's
the parent that says you cannot bring
drugs back into my home
yeah that is the girlfriend that says i
love you and
you're going to drown us both and i'm
not going to not
i'm not going to sign up for this
because this is going to be a long
horrible life
right and so this idea the the courage
and bravery it takes to say
i love you and i value
my ability to breathe but anali if
you're that person i'm talking about
not the one john was talking about a
minute ago that you're generally fairly
uh self-confident you need to know that
your
desire for love in this particular
situation has flipped your language
out of the abundance of the heart the
mouth speaks your language says
codependence all over it
you know so let me kind of go back my
boyfriend has almost eight million times
more debt than i do
but he thinks you can't make money
without spending it how do i make him
see he's hurting himself i'm trying to
get my boyfriend and i
out of debt yeah you me i'm going to fix
him i'm going to fix him i'm going to
fix him as well i says over and over and
over again
and there's a guy over there with a
backhoe digging holes and you've got
your shovel and you're like how do i how
do i
fill it up and faster than he can dig it
up he can dig it faster than you that's
right yeah you're digging out the bottom
faster than you're ever gonna get there
so i want you to put that shovel down
and go get some give you a high
probability on this anally
um as the old guy the uh that's a
walking dead joke
okay um high probability is
that if you are a woman young woman of
confidence
and a good self-esteem uh that this
young man is not going to change fast
enough to keep you around
you're going to move on because i don't
think he's marriage material
i know he's not marriage material today
and because john
opened up with run that was his opening
answer
was run and and i like to think of these
calls as what do i do if
josephine comes home from college and
says that i found a guy
right yeah and dave you may not have
experienced this
and that's me being sarcastic i'm sure
you did but sheila had people sit down
and
and talk to her like are you sure you
know what you're doing with him
right like they would take her out kept
sharing away from those
oh man they found sheila are you sure
she's like i'm sure
um her parents had to be rolling their
eyes when they when i walked in i
wouldn't let my daughter date me
not in a million years oh man i don't
even go down that road
but so there is that right but but um
yeah but sharon did not take me on as a
project no
and i didn't take her on as a project we
were both projects but we didn't take
each other everybody
right but yes sheila did not get her
self-esteem by saying i'm gonna fix john
right yeah it's just good parenting to
run those guys off if you have the
opportunity
you know i'm just like daddy all the
boys in the youth group are scared of
you and i went good
keeps away two things wusses and jerks
don't need either one dating my daughter
that keeps away more than
it keeps wearing wusses and jerks pretty
well
you put most things in those two buckets
oh they're the same bucket well you know
there's some time
at times sometimes but it's just run in
a lee run
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two john and ashley
are with us in new hampshire it says on
my screen you guys are
debt-free congratulations thank you
thank you
well done how much have you paid off 75
000.
all right how long did this take 11
months
good for you and your range of income
during that time
105 to 120 000. cool what do you guys do
for a living
we work for your friends at the kgb
actually
okay cool hey that that admittedly took
me a second because
anyone in my life who would actually
know the real kgb it'd probably be dave
so it took me a second but i got it now
ah again the irs yes
the uh the phone calls that i take with
individuals that owe balances are
a lot different now i educate a lot now
well thank you thank you that's very
good
so tell us your story what kind of debt
was this
we had and one auto loan but it was
multiple
uh upside downs wrapped into one so it
was like a 650 dollar
payment for one auto loan yes
student loans we financed our bed
we had a best buy card for the washer
and dryer
and that was it the way you said we
financed our bed
so we just kept getting heard him make
fun of people for doing that before
you finessed what yeah yeah well
yeah haven't we all and and so how long
have you guys been married
uh a little over three years okay so
what happened 11 months ago what was the
turning point
uh it's uh well we were on our way to
make another
bad financial decision we were going to
our credit union to ask about their
40-year mortgage offer
and then they told us that we could sit
down with
a financial advisor because we were
members so we got an hour
and he said uh you guys have a bad debt
to
income ratio so maybe hold off on that
oh when the bank won't take your money
that's when you know you got a problem
right
yeah so i mean i went home after
speaking with him and
you know just did what most people do
just checked out videos on youtube and
the algorithm hit you know dave ramsey
videos and i don't know i
spent probably the next two weeks just
analyzing and
analyzing until i finally brought it to
ashley's attention she was like why'd
you wait so long let's go
let's do this ah okay
we bought a pu right after that and it
was kind of
you know hit the ground running just go
game on
when the uh when the student is ready
the teacher will appear huh
exactly yeah the app said it was going
to take 20 months and we did it in 11.
yeah well that's because you decided to
do it all and do it all
with a game on attitude i'm proud of you
mess with irs agents
yeah very well
what was the movie men in black they
will get it done
did you flashy thing me yeah
oh man you guys that's impressive so
well done
so what do you now that you did it now
that you're successful
you've successfully got out of debt
something congress can't do
what uh what would you tell people the
key to getting out of that ass
budget for sure we thought we were only
going to have a hundred dollars extra
a month to put it the debt and when we
did the budget we found
two thousand dollars that we could put
towards the budget without
overtime wow yes and saying no
we have three young kids so we learned
quickly to say no
okay and they didn't they didn't die
they didn't
they run away they didn't leave you
they're not in counseling yeah
right no no they're they're perfectly
fine they're happy with it actually
we explained to them what we were doing
and they loved watching the colors of
the
car loan you know getting higher with us
paying it off they would come in and
check
every day and they'd get mad at us if it
didn't
you know go down wow turned it into a
game
yeah yeah they were our biggest
cheerleaders that's fun
good for you guys well it sounds like
there's a lot of transformation happened
in the house during this time
yeah for sure so talk to me about that
drive home
with your head held low to
that husband who's like man i got to
figure this out to how's your marriage
now
um well communication um is obviously
the way that we both work there i mean
everyone like critiques us for like
or just ask you know how do you spend 24
7 with each other
um you know and do all and it's because
of the communication and
you know we tackled it together you know
for sure so
i am the numbers guy and i just i would
sit there and
crunch and crunch but she just would
make it work she took over with the
budget we'd have the meetings and
you know she'd sit in there and do the
transactions and
so it's just the the constant
communication back and forth the
teamwork
the precisely i love it well done you
guys
very well done i'm so proud of you so
um this is an interesting thing i want
to follow the thread through
you meet with the financial advisor at
the credit union he says you have too
high a debt to income ratio
meaning you is broke and you come home
uh spend a couple of weeks uh pouring
over youtube videos that leads you into
financial peace university
what do you feel like looking back on
that journey you've been through was the
core
message that you got from us that caused
you to be able to do this
to me preparing for the future
um you know kind of like dr john said
you know me hanging my head down though
like how do i
figure this out well that was just for
us to try to
get out of you know my parents home with
three kids we were living with
my parents and you know i was like how
can i
you know fix this you know with what it
was my student loans and
you know that was one of the biggest
problems um
but you know it was just
you know pushing through and um you know
looking forward to the ability to set
them up
educate them so that they don't make the
same mistakes that i do
um so it's kind of like you're more
willing to sacrifice when you have a
higher calling something other than just
i want to back rep
mine was the give part yeah being able
to get to the point where i couldn't
give back
yeah that was the biggest thing for me
other than setting my kids up for
success
but yeah but change your family tree and
generosity your non-selfish
noble higher calling goals
versus i want to buy a nice car exactly
and by the way you can do both you don't
have to they're not mutually exclusive
but
but i want to buy a nice car someday
isn't enough motivation to sacrifice
i want to change my kids lives you can
sacrifice
the six-year-old's already saving for a
tesla
because he's not going to borrow money
from the bank he said he's going to save
for it now
i like this guy when he's 55 he'll have
earned that money to afford that car
he's got like 200 already well he'll
have more than elon has himself so there
you go
i love it congratulations you guys we're
so proud of you we got a copy of rachel
cruz's book for you her latest new york
times bestseller
it's called know yourself know your
money you guys are an impressive couple
thank you so much for sharing your story
with us
john and ashley from new hampshire 75
000 paid off in 11 months making 105 to
120.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one
[Music]
i think i heard that family tree joining
in man that's the way it's supposed to
be
the roots called that on that one that's
the way the sound that's the way this
the sound of a family tree changing
right there
when that you get that chipmunk voice
going in there with it that's that's
when you know you're on on
track baby man that gives me goosebumps
when i hear the kids yelling
it's fun stuff uh that means they were
plugged in they were dialed in they knew
what was going on and that's
uh sophia they got it on our screen here
sophia jackson and grayson were joining
in there so
congratulations they got to watch mom
and dad do hard things
and they learned hey we can do hard
things
and i man there's something about
growing up in a debt free house that's a
legacy shift there's something about
giving your kid
you know a car and a house and paid for
college that's cool
there's also something about letting
your kids watch you struggle and learn
and go
heard no no and they think
powerful words i can do hard stuff
yeah mom and dad can do hard stuff i can
do hard stuff
love it this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
if you ever ask questions like how much
should i be saving
or how do i get out of that faster or
what's the right way to invest or
i don't know where to learn about money
well here's the good news you don't have
to figure all this out on your own
ramsey plus
will guide you every step of the way
with a ramsey plus membership you get
all the digital teaching in financial
peace university and
other classes you need to really
understand money so you can be
confident you're always doing the next
right thing the budgeting app
every dollar is pretty amazing the tools
the guided action steps
they help you make progress on your
money goals really really fast and that
means
no more debt cash in the bank for
emergencies
a real plan for your future a sense of
peace and power
around your money ramsay plus helps you
get small
consistent wins every day that cause you
to have the big results
and the lifelong habit change you get
started today with a free trial text
trial at 33 789 text
trial 233 789. dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today
john is with us in atlanta hi john
welcome to the ramsay show hi dave
thanks for having me
sure how can we help well dave i'm
calling in
because i'm 27 years old um i've got
a stable job with the federal government
that pays pretty well
and i'm just kind of looking forward
at my future here and it seems like
a lot of the people who stay in this
position
kind of end up losing passion for what
they do
and i'm starting to notice myself losing
passion for what i do and so
you know when i bring this up with my
family they kind of tell me um
you should stick with it you've got a
pension there um you know you've got
ironclad job security but i feel like
if i stay here i'm gonna i'm gonna go
crazy however i wanted to know
i'm 27. how long you been there man
two years how many two years
two and what is it you do exactly daily
um well i work as a statistician so
basically i'm you know they try to
automate a lot of the things that my
organization does now
and so i'm involved with that
what do you love doing man
well um i i do love working with numbers
i do love
um statistics it's what i studied in
school why is this driving me crazy then
well it's driving me crazy because i
just don't uh
i don't know it just doesn't seem like
the people who work here are very
passionate about what they do
i mean um yeah you're
i don't let's don't care about them for
a second what about you
it's okay to be in a room where you like
what you're doing even if the people
around you don't
um no because the problem sorry the
problem is that
what a lot of the times what ends up
happening is that if you're passionate
you know you end up getting extra work
but because of the way the system works
there's not really
there's not really much advancement so
it just becomes frustrating
what what does the word passionate mean
to you
i've been hearing my students use that
word passionate for years
now what does that mean to you
well i i suppose that what it means is
that sometimes
you know you wake up in the morning and
you don't want to do something
and it's okay to feel like that
sometimes
but if you feel like that day after day
after day
um then that means that you lack passion
so passion means that
i guess over a long period of time you
can look back at what you've done and
say
you know i really enjoyed doing that
that really
that really made me feel like i was
doing something important
good answer okay so what's the downside
with you going to work someplace else
well i would lose um i would lose my job
security for one thing
you don't have any job security there's
no such thing you work for the federal
government brother
yeah they lay people off today
they lay people off too they're probably
not going to go broke i don't think
but um but they lay people off too and
your job you're only as secure as your
ability to do things that people want to
pay you for
and if you're a statistician who likes
statistics you're going to be
employable for a long time in a
data-driven world
yeah this whole world's driven off of
data right now and you're a data analyst
if there ever was one right
right yeah yeah i mean i suppose they
probably can make twice as much money
yeah if not three times yeah i'm sure
yeah i'm sure it's just a you know
security
security is an illusion dude it's a drug
brother yeah you need to get out of
there
um because i mean you're 27 years old
project this out you're going to be 57
30
years of doing this you already sound
old right now
i can't imagine how long you'll sound
then that's a great line i was trying to
think what he's not depressed but you
just sound old man
you sound 74. yeah you know can you
imagine how old you're going to be when
you're 57.
good god you'll be a thousand
in government
hey listen the people around you the
people who
who are giving you advice um they mean
well but they're just wrong
they yeah they are telling you they love
you in the only language they know how
which is
you being safe and you'd be insecure
which we know is an illusion but they're
doing the best they can with what they
got and at some point you've got to get
off the drug of
safety get off the illusion of safety
and jump so john one of my heroes was my
grandpa
in the great depression uh he was 27
years old oddly enough
and he in the in the stock market crash
he lost a business
and went and went broke and alcoa
aluminum had come to alcoa tennessee
in the hills of east tennessee and
opened a plant and he went to work for
them
he worked there 38 years and never left
because of the fear
partly because of the fear of uh having
gone broke when he was young
and partly because he was a good man and
wanted to provide for his family
and the stability of that was there in
that environment my grandmother became
really dependent upon that security that
you're talking about
and uh humorous story uh the first time
i sold my millionth
book i've sold about 20 million now
about the time i sold my millionth book
which means i had made
millions and millions of dollars okay if
you can imagine
my grandmother called and still was
worried about me
running my own little business when are
you gonna get a real job dave that's
exactly what she said
she called up and said honey i'm worried
about you when are you gonna get a real
job and i had just sold my millionth
book
now she's sweet and i understood where
she was coming from because i know the
story
and my grandpa was my hero and i
understand
he's just one of my favorite people that
i ever knew on this planet
i miss him greatly to this day but the
uh
and i and i loved her i loved her too as
well she's sweet as she could be
but in her that was her love language
from the environment and the situation
the way they had lived life
was to say when are you going to get a
real job and she meant well
uh john just like the people in your
life mean well but i had just sold a
million bucks so i think we can safely
say the
data the statistical evidence is that
she was wrong
okay and here's the thing if you go out
on your own
and you give it three or four years and
it doesn't work my guess is
you could probably get a job and get
your job right back that's right
maybe not that exact one with that exec
department or whatever but whoopty dope
d
uh you you have a marketable skill in a
data-driven world
data is the businesses that don't
understand grasp and harness the data
the power of data
in the next decade we'll be out of
business correct it's not optional so
you are a highly sought after
individual in your world and so that
that's
um i'm telling you i think you're
probably making about half or maybe a
fourth of what you're worth
and you're giving it all up in the name
of security that's not really there
anyway
get out yeah you can just hear i can
hear your soul leaking it out
just leaking out of your body out get
out get out
get out yeah there's something there's
something to be said for i want you to
be safe
and so i want you to drown slowly right
i want you to be safe well i don't think
everyone should be an entrepreneur no
absolutely i don't think everyone should
be on straight commission i don't mean
that
but you know you're only as secure as
your own ability to land the next thing
because you have talent
yeah and people want to work with you
yeah yeah
marketable skills and personality and
so forth that's your that's your only
real security because everything else is
smoke and mirrors the guy making the
payroll he's
he's scared too yeah and you think
you're secure
that's funny you know this is the ramsey
show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer for
the ramsay show
this episode is over but if you heard
about an event product or service and
didn't have a chance to write it down
don't worry we list everything you've
heard about during this episode of the
podcast show notes section
or head to thermzyshow.com thanks for
[Music]
listening
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios
it's the ramsey show where debt is dumb
cash is king
and the paid off home mortgage has taken
the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host dr john deloney ramsey
personality best-selling author is my
co-host today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five
five two two five
jennifer starts off this hour in
washington dc hi jennifer welcome to the
ramsey
show hi thank you so much for taking my
call
sure what's up so my husband will be
retiring from the coast guard
next summer summer 2022
and we plan to move back home to
colorado springs
so we currently have 150 000 down
for a home to purchase and the question
that we have is
because the market is just crazy right
now and homes are flying
you know off the market and 20 to 50 000
over asked
should we start the process now knowing
that we're not going to pay over asking
um you know should we start looking at
houses now and then buying something and
just letting it set empty if we end up
buying something or should we just wait
until we actually get out there
and we also don't have any jobs lined up
yet either
how long has he been serving um it'll be
22 years next summer
my goodness well tell him thanks for his
service we appreciate it and you too you
guys have moved all over the world
haven't you
um yeah we have thank you yeah i'm glad
you're settling in it's good it's a good
it's a good time of life for you and
you're gonna have a nightmare and i
think i'm also a little bit
i have i think i have house fever
because we've been renting for so long
yeah you you've got you've got kind of a
nesting instinct kicking in almost here
it's like
finally i get to get my place and i'm
wanting to do it and all these people
went crazy with their houses after
coving and they're messing up my plan
yes yeah i don't blame you i get i get
where you are
i don't disagree um so the only reason
you would go ahead and do all of that
now is if you believe that
this white hot crazy upbid market
is going to continue for 12 to 18 months
i personally don't think it's going to
continue at this
fever pitch this fever pitch is is the
is the other end of the the other side
of the coin
of covid freezing the entire economy
shut
because everybody stayed home and they
were afraid lokovid was going to get on
them and
uh and so they stayed home the
government told them to stay home they
stayed home and it shut the economy down
and then all this pent up demand it's
like the whole economy held its breath
it's like holding a hose right yeah all
the the whole economy held its breath
and it finally sticks his head up above
water and goes
and that's what it's doing and so i
think it's you know just like if you
come out of the pool
after being on the bottom of the pool
yeah you can't get your breath trying to
get your breath
you know you're you're you're
hyperventilating almost and then within
10 minutes what happens
kind of everything levels off and quote
you know
calms down and that's what i think is
going to happen with housing
so i don't think that that this this
hose being pinched and then released
or you know breath being held at the
bottom of the pool and then finally
released is going to be the continued
version of the economy for the next five
years
i don't know net net net if the house
prices are going to end up higher
or not honestly colorado springs has
been a very hot market for a very long
time
and so it's going to be a tough market
in terms of buying a house
but the uh you know of course you've got
a huge military presence there
spoken on the base there and so there's
always going to be some housing turnover
because of that
uh but it's it's a highly desirable city
to live in
and quality of life and you know
lifestyle and everything and so
um uh and so there's always been a lot
of activity around it as long as i can
remember
uh it's been a strong market uh but i i
don't
know and so all of that to say
i think the feelings you're having are
natural
especially given your situation uh
but but i wouldn't worry about it i just
wait till you get out
go out there get your jobs if you rent
for a year
to do the right thing it's not going to
kill you and by then i think this
hyperventilating market is going to get
back to a normal breathing pattern
of some kind does that make sense
yeah it definitely makes sense i think i
just need an outside perspective to calm
me down
yeah your instincts are right on both
ends right you know
this is put out a good time to buy and
i gotta buy something right now right
yeah i think you you accurately
accurately uh diagnosed yourself
[Laughter]
which is good news self-awareness is
always a sign of mental of good mental
health there's only like 18 people in
the country that have that so
good for you and and not many of them
are in washington dc so you're a real
rarity
she won't be for long going to colorado
springs yeah she's leaving
get out while the getting's good uh yeah
thank you for your service again i
appreciate you i would just be calm
and uh while all about you have lost
their head
you keep your head and just just go this
is what's right
this is what's right and there's no
better place to be when i'm getting
things cool
i'm going to have an end breathe and an
outbreak pile of cash to
a rhythm with a big 150 000 bucks in my
right hand
and i'm just going to sit here and
breathe a little bit yeah that's a good
floaty right yeah that's a good floaty
on the
pool pool metaphor here it's gonna beat
this metaphor to death yeah yeah
just wear it out all right david is with
us david's in kalamazoo
michigan hey david what's up
hi guys thanks for taking my call um
awesome thank you for the everydollar
app that thing that we
we love it well thank you
so my question today is i listen to your
podcast all the time i don't think i've
ever heard you talk about
works uh how irps yeah
because i don't because i wouldn't ever
tell anybody to do one
can you kind of explain i haven't got a
good explanation of how it even works or
what the advantage
over the wasp just having a lot
well basically it's a sophisticated
version
of cash value life insurance
it's a life insurance retirement plan
lirp and you're using
life insurance as an investment vehicle
which is the definition of sucks
and um you're using life insurance as an
investment vehicle to create your
retirement plan
it's a horrible rate of return it's very
inefficient
and but the insurance world
does the very best they can to sell this
garbage and package it up
90 000 different ways and this is yet
one more way they packaged it
and they try to create some kind of
narrative or language around it where
people will continue to be
snuffed by it but basically anytime you
buy life insurance as an investment you
have a bad rate of return
and often most often the way the deals
are structured is when you die
the money you have in the investment is
built into the insurance
they pay out the insurance and keep the
investment and it just never works out
that's the typical whole life policy
that's a variable life policy that's a
indexed universal policy a double
backflip
circus policy i mean they just make up
crap you know and
you know so it's it's really
anytime you hear investing in life
insurance there's one word you need to
remember
run buy life insurance for death only
do your investing in real investments
don't buy your mufflers
at the transmission store
[Music]
hey folks i got a great option to help
you pay for your education
the army national guard the army
national guard believes you
are the next greatest generation because
you have proven that
even in adversity that you have what it
takes to succeed
that's why they offer benefits like
tuition assistance career training
and a paycheck to help you avoid debt no
matter what your goals are the army
national guard can help you
get there visit nationalguard.com to
find out more
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
this is the ramsey show if there's one
thing we all need to know by now
it's that you cannot invest alone
you need someone in your life who knows
the market better than you
is in it every day and helps you make
smart
decisions to respond to it look i love
do-it-yourselfers i'm a do-it-yourselfer
but i don't pull my own teeth
and i don't work on my own cars anymore
i don't even know what they do when i
lift the hood it doesn't even look like
anything i used to turn a wrench on
25 years ago they're completely
different and i would tear it up
tear up a perfectly good car with uh
that or i probably would mess up my
dental work
where i have to do it myself so i
actually bring in professionals
now do i take everything that everyone
says
and believe a hundred percent of it no i
expect them to teach me
if the mechanic comes out and says you
need to spend a thousand dollars i want
to know
why i want to know what's broken and how
it works
and what are we going to do to fix it i
don't want just oh yeah
they just tell you what to do i don't i
when a doctor says you know you have
this and i'm like well what's that mean
you're gonna have to teach me you know
the tax guy says you need to do this i'm
like i don't do it blindly i wanna know
why i wanna know why i'm that little boy
eight-year-old boy why
why why why why which is how you
properly invest
by the way you don't just throw your
money at some dude in a suit or some
lady in a dress and go take care of my
money and then walk out the door and
hope it works out it won't
this is how people lose their money so
you get someone in your corner and you
ask why
and how and they have the heart of a
teacher and they will walk you through
the right kind of a process this
is how you become wealthy oh and by the
way when you're scared or you're worried
about the economy
or the news comes on and says the stock
market dropped today and that
you're like oh no i've just lost all my
retirement no you didn't
call and talk to your advisor and
they'll talk to you about the history of
market fluctuations
and how life really works and they'll
talk you off the ledge and let your
little emotions calm down and then you
can continue to invest
because the only one that gets hurt on a
roller coaster are those that jump off
in the middle of the freaking ride
so you need someone like a smartvestor
pro with that heart of a teacher
and that experience and that know-how
to show you what you understand so you
can invest and stay
invested text the word invest to 33 789
that's texting invest to 33789
and we'll create a rock solid investing
plan with one of our smart investor pros
today
they don't work for us but these are men
and women across the nation in your
neighborhood
that i proudly endorse they are trusted
by ramsey alicia is with us in orlando
hi alicia welcome to the dave ram
after the ramsey show with dr john
deloney how are you
hi good afternoon sirs thank you so much
for
giving me some hopefully a great
financial advice
we'll try um i've had a hit very bad
financial history and it's taken me over
12 years to get out from where i was and
i am fearful
of repeating history so after all
my expenses are taking care of each
month i have an additional 4 000
that i don't know what to do with wow
look at you yeah it's it's been
long to get out of it so wait a minute
let's talk about it a minute what was
what's your income
but um i earn 150 every year what do you
do
oh i work in insurance you're amazing
well done
very well done so uh you said it's been
a long shlog out of the mess how long
did it take you to get out of the mess
uh just over about 10 years
was it an income mess you didn't have a
good income or was it uh
you did stupid mistakes very stupid
mistakes i was
um one of millions of people that were
caught up in the 2008 housing market
and i bought a house i couldn't afford
and it's just it was ever since then
i could not get out of it and i'm
finally at a place
when did you get out of there i
had a short sale and after filing
bankruptcy
um 2012
was when i finally got out from under
that so from 2012 to today
uh nine years you've been progressively
doing smarter and smarter things and
have not added any dumb things to the
list
no sir that's pretty good you got a
decade of clean
it's been hard i learned my lesson and i
do not want to go there
i've had my car repossessed i've had not
not in nine years you haven't no no that
was all part of yeah i know
downfall of the 2008. let me tell you
what i'm hearing john and i talk about
this a lot let me tell you what i heard
the language you're using you're still
living back there in the pain and the
shame
no shame i'm proud you haven't you
haven't got to be
you ought to be very proud you've got a
whole decade of being awesome
oh thank you i'm but i'm scared well i
mean that's okay my wife's scared
we went broke 30 years ago she still
looks at me like i'm crazy occasionally
and listen all that means is your
brain's working just fine yeah
it's seen how bad things can get and it
never wants to let you do that again
and it's willing here's the thing it's
like you get near the edge of that cliff
you're like no you can fall
you know your brain we will smoke a
cigarette to calm down today
and it will kill us tomorrow all our
brain wants to do is take care of us
right this second so
as soon as you start seeing this money
and you start thinking about it
it conjures up all the old to keep you
in the straight and narrow but that can
rob you of joy and fun
and all of the rewards of this stuff
you've worked so hard for
what i want you to hear is is i'm
talking to a lady that makes 150 000
a year and has made good financial
decisions for a decade you know what
that makes you
a freaking unicorn you're unusually
awesome
you're incredible it's just
learning from where i don't want to be
again that was
my only driving force and the next phase
is to
not run from things but to run tucson
yeah and listen when your brain tries to
protect you
it means everything's working great and
all you have to say is
thanks for checking in i'm doing great i
make 150 grand
brain and i don't make stupid decisions
anymore brain and then
you feel free to share your life with
other people and man you are off to the
races alicia
okay so what we need to do is we need to
assign
a task that is future oriented because
the past
has passed that's future oriented to
these four thousand dollars a month that
you have
and so are you single yes do you own a
home
yes okay how much do you owe on it
um well i think it's roughly around
uh 4 20 now okay and
what do you do you have any other debt
no sir
and you have how much saved
um so i have no retirement savings
i have my six-month emergency fund of 30
000. good and you've heard us talk about
the baby steps where you put
at this stage you are baby step four and
you put
my first time i'm gonna cost you guys
i'm sorry but
it's okay it's all right you have your
emergency fund and you're debt free but
the house that brings you to what we
call baby step
four which is fifteen percent of your
income going into retirement
five is kids college i don't think that
applies in your situation
and baby step six is pay off your house
early so we're going to put 15 percent
of your income
into retirement that's going to be 22
500
in your life per year about 2 000 a
month going into retirement
and then everything above that that you
have free you're either going to spend
it
and or throw it as extra payments on the
house to pay off the house early
and my estimation is is that as your
income continues to grow you're going to
pay off this house in under 10 years
from where you are and you're going to
be in a very amazing place with your
retirement 10 years from today
because you start saving 22 000 a year 2
000 a month
24 000 a year somewhere in there you're
gonna be rocking it kiddo
and so your future's bright because
of what you learned in the past and i
don't want
any listener to blow by dave's wisdom
here
when the gazelle takes off he's running
or she is running from a lion
and when that when that threat is over
then that that gazelle has to go towards
friends it's got to go towards a new
watering source towards new green grass
it's got to go to stuff not always keep
sprinting and sprinting sprinting yeah
you can only run away from things so
long you start out you need to run
two things this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kwashira
is with us hey kwasher how are you hi
dave hi john welcome where do you live i
live in charlotte north carolina
welcome to nashville all the way over
here to do a debt-free scream
yes sir how much you pay off 82 thousand
dollars
and how long did this take 26 months wow
and your range of income during that
time
i started at 56 000 and last year i
grossed
122. whoa yes you doubled your income
i did in two years yes well first i have
to hear how you did that
i took a leap of faith and i took
another career path and now i'm a
mortgage loan officer so
pretty much where were you before a
premier banker
so doing credit cards yes so you took
you took the private banking knowledge
the premier banking knowledge
and you how to serve clients
particularly high-end clients roll into
the mortgage business and go
touchdown absolutely perfect timing
what a time to get into the mortgage
business yeah and what a time to take
that skill set and use it well
done well done i love it what kind of
debt was the 82 000
well i financed uh iphone security
system
i had to pay taxes i took out a 401k
loan to
put money down on a house i bought i had
two car notes i had to buy my mom a car
she just had to have a car right
in my opinion so small credit card debt
and the largest one was 52 000 student
loans
god you just did everything yes i mean
you're like normal
pretty normal plus a little a little
extra normal on there
correct hey and here's what makes all of
this ironic you worked for a bank
yes i do work for a bank you knew better
yeah well
yeah no she was telling people to do the
same stuff all day exactly there you go
yeah so uh what what happened
it changed all this yeah it's a few
things i was talking to one of my
supervisors
and just a little jim he asked me how
much did i have in my savings and i told
him
about three or four thousand at the time
he said how much debt do you have and i
was just counting the student loans so i
said 53 thousand dollars
he was like well you don't have a
savings so i was like okay that makes
sense i feel like that sparked it and
then somehow i really don't remember how
but i came across your book i read it
and then i i went down a
loophole of watching debt free screams
and there was this one particular story
where this lady she was single like
myself
she made the same amount of money she
paid off the same amount of debt i'm
like if she could do it i surely can do
it yeah
i took off from there and now somebody's
watching you yes
yeah and they're gonna do it because you
did that i hope so thank you
thank you you're very inspiring very
very fun
82 026 months
yes so you read the book and then you
went down the rabbit hole of youtube and
watched um
because there's thousands of debt free
streams on youtube i mean we've got
we've got them all on our
youtube channel about a billion
downloads on on the podcast now and
literally and so people are doing this
all the time
yes uh and what a good i mean you just
it like that just fills up your spirit
yes other people winning yelling
yeah that's cool that's going to be me
yeah what was the first thing you
actually
did then with this new motivation yeah i
am i'm a very goal-oriented person and i
like to see
things on paper so i wrote down all of
my debt and my goal was just to be
debt-free by 30.
i started this when i was 26. so four
years was plenty enough time
but of course you know our lord and
savior sped that up
it just kept things just kept lining up
where income increasing
checks were coming you know i took on
extra jobs
etc so just got after it yeah i've
watched this for years and i've
um the now or the metaphor that i've
used is
that it's like god is sitting up there
going oh
look there's one that's now smart i can
trust this one
because when you're faithful with the
little things you're given more to
manage that's scriptural
and it's almost as if you're walking
along and you step up on one of those
moving sidewalks at the airport
and now you're still walking but you're
moving even faster yes
and like god just takes you faster than
your little legs who take you by
yourself absolutely he let me finish
this
um a month after well actually the same
month i turned 29 so
again he fast tracked my plan yeah his
plans was always better than ours so
you're faster hey man you're faster than
you thought you were going to correct
yeah way to go thank you who is your
biggest cheerleader
um you know my family is always going to
support me but outside of that i feel
like just watching
listening to your show daily i mean i
would take roaches i would listen to on
the plane
i did uber and lift for his time i would
play it in the car so just
keeping you on and again just watching
youtube videos kept me motivated
with the listeners looking to do what
i'm doing when did you make the jump to
mortgages
july of 2019 and i finished july 2020.
okay so one year of the two years was at
a potentially higher income correct
or a higher income certainly you've been
i'm sure the mortgage business has
gotten better every month
absolutely yeah and um and you did all
this through covid
correct which was great for me a lot of
folks are taking advantage of
not having to pay student loans and i
thought it was a great opportunity to
pay student loans since
all my money is going towards principal
versus interest so of course
again i guess just gazelle that as well
yeah very what was it what was
give us a moment you got scared things
things got dicey
um it's a long journey um you know i
tell any anyone it's
it's one of the hardest things i ever
did it's simple and i need simple it's a
simple plan to follow but it's one of
the hardest things i ever did so
just just trying to stick with it and
just remembering hey this is temporary
this is going to be two years and i'm
only 29 i have my entire life
to live financially free so when it got
scary you just backed up and had
perspective
correct remember remembering the goal
yeah and remember where i'm gonna be
what's gonna feel like exactly
yeah that's a big deal that's very
strong
that's very strong you're an amazing
young woman i'm so proud of you thank
you
i'm sure your mom's proud of you she
came with you who else came with you yes
my mom and my sister
all right family is supporting yes i
like it this is very very cool
well congratulations thank you so much
very well done so you tell people the
key to getting out of debt is
yeah so um stay the course again it may
get weary but just
stick with it you you're literally
almost probably close to finishing if
you thinking about quitting
lowering your expenses and increasing
your income is a big one
i got rid of streaming services um i
went from 120
cell phone bill down to 50. my folks
actually laugh at me because my service
isn't that great but my bill is 50
so and i don't want to talk to you
anyway it's right exactly
after talking on the phone with my
clients um discipline and sacrifice
those are those are the keys for me
we're getting out of debt yeah yeah you
you uh
you really uh
you were so game on i mean you you
identified the target like you said you
said i'm goal oriented
but you really are you're that's not
just that's the way your brain works and
once you set that thing
and then it's game on correct you know
and there's no stopping you and and
uh did you learn anything about yourself
during this journey
um i would say i can really do whatever
i
really put my mind to you kind of
already knew that yeah
yeah this just gave you more confidence
correct yeah
yeah because you weren't lacking in
confidence before no you you gotta
you gotta meet your mama raise your
right that's awesome yeah you got a
presence about you that's powerful
wow thank you cool well done
well we got a copy of rachel cruz's
latest new york times bestseller know
yourself know your money for you thank
you i will add that to your collection
of ramsey books and
you're an impressive young woman well
done all right aquishera from charlotte
north
carolina 82 000 paid off in 26 months
making 56 to 122. count it down
let's hear a debt free scream three
two one i'm
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
man oh man oh man oh man
i don't know a lot but when kashira has
a goal i'm not going to get between her
and that goal
no you wouldn't want to no and i don't i
i i also don't know a lot but i think
you just got a parenting principle
woven into that that mom taught that kid
how to be that kind of woman how
to have self-worth how to have goals how
to
i to know i can do hard things all of it
you have value and that means you can go
get whatever you'll get zero
chance no that woman's gonna be a victim
nope
she's gonna adopt a victim position of
any kind
ever there's a do not get in her way
that's cool i'm gonna run
right through it that's incredible
it's incredible because shears mom i see
you
and you're inspiring me because i'm
raising a little girl and you're
inspiring me
amen yeah we'll build a warrior princess
baby that's how you do it
wow pretty incredible
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture today james 1 4 let
perseverance finish its work
so that you may be mature and complete
not lacking
anything benjamin franklin said
energy and persistence conquer
all things dr john deloney ramsey
personality is my co-host today as we
take your
questions about life and about money the
phone number is triple
eight eight two five five two two five
jessica is with us she's in wilmington
north carolina hi jessica
how can we help hi dave hi hi dr d how
are you all today
great what's up great um so my husband
and i
are trying to figure out if we can
afford for me to start my career
so just some quick details we re we
recently finished
baby step two um working on baby step
three which will probably take us about
five more months i'm going to be going
into real estate so they're going to be
some
startup costs associated with that
probably around like
1200 with mls access and
the exams and everything like that but
we will have to
figure out getting child care for our
son
so my husband is in the military we
could utilize the base daycare for about
600 a month but we're wondering if we
should essentially
pause baby step 3 and save the money
for my startup in a few months of child
care to cover that gap in between
when i start and when i get my first
commission check or if we should finish
up baby step three
and then save up for those costs
associated with me
starting work
eighteen hundred dollars takes you
through the first
month twelve hundred dollars worth of
costs and six hundred dollars worth of
day care right
mm-hmm that should be right yep okay
um how old are you uh we are both
22 22
yes okay and have you had discussions
with a real estate broker that you would
go to work for
yes i have i have um been in the office
several times to speak with them and
um have interests with a particular
brokerage
and what's their training program like
and what do they project before you to
make your first sale
um so they have told me
one of the girls who i've been talking
to she said that it took her
about six weeks to get her first
contract but there are other girls
in the office who um they've
gotten a contract within the first few
weeks and some
longer so um that is
the part what is going to be your delete
what's going to be your lead source
um they i'm not 100
sure still trying to figure out all of
those details
okay and what does your husband make a
year
he makes around 40 000 a year
why real estate um it's always something
that i have been
interested in and you know i have
a passion to help people and i figure
um taking my interest and my passion
mixing that together could be a good
idea all right let me
tell you the full picture of what i'm
hearing and what's also running through
my head
okay and then let's kind of put all that
on the table and we'll start playing
with it and trying to figure out what to
do
i got my real estate license when i
turned 18 years old
um i did sell a house three weeks later
because to one of my high school buddies
because i was just out of high school
which means both of us were pretty
stupid actually
but um i mean who buys a house from an
18 year old except another 18 year old
right so
um but the uh uh or a 19 year old or
something like that i mean this is like
happy days does real estate or something
but the um
uh uh but by and large
uh and i sold real estate actively
all the way through college from 18 to
22 years old
and then and i've had my licenses ever
since
so uh what you're saying can be done
uh i will tell you from experience male
or female
um it is very it's an uphill battle to
have credibility
to get someone to make the largest
purchase that they ever make in their
life with a 22 year old
it's uh it can be done but you're going
to have people that just simply will not
work with you because of your age
because you just don't have credibility
and uh or they're
you know they like you you're sweet uh
pat you on the head but won't do but
won't actually close the deal you know
what i'm saying
that's a lot different than the crusty
old uh
you know 56 year old battle axe right um
that just tells everybody what to do and
they do it you know kind of thing it's
you're just in a different position in
your life in terms of credibility so you
need to know that you're
this is not a hot knife through butter
it can be done right
but but you've got you've got some
uphill stuff i did it i don't i
i think you can do it i think you should
do it but
um all of those things contribute to the
idea that it's probably going to take
a little while before you actually start
making money
right and so that tells me i want your
emergency fund in place before you do
this
and that also tells me that the fastest
way to cause that to happen and the
fastest way to have then the money
for the licensing and the daycare
months before you get money coming in
probably means you look at some other
form of extra income as a short-term way
to to get to your goal of being in real
estate faster
right like i mean if you could find
something and make a thousand fifteen
hundred bucks two thousand bucks a month
as a part-time gig doing something and
it just
you do the work it pays something uber
eats deliver pizzas
i don't care what you do or they'll hire
you to do something at that real estate
office for a couple grand
that would even be better uh and you're
just you know you just start
immediately doing that and i would
rather you do that than work real estate
today until you and
and use that money to get the emergency
fund finished faster and use that money
to get a little bit of a nest egg to
to go six months of day care and
1200 worth of upfront expenses and
you're gonna have more than that after i
after all it's probably gonna be more
like 2000 by the time you're done
um and so i i just want you to have all
that and
because nothing smells quite as bad as a
broke desperate salesperson
you're right and i i just have spoke to
s
with so many folks who want to get into
the real estate business that's why i
asked you what you want to do
because the ma the napkin math is so
great we just have to sell five houses
and i get this cut of this price and
honey we're gonna be rich and it's super
flexible so i don't even have to deal
with the little one anymore right
and everyone who i know dave and you've
done it i haven't it gets into real
estate it is
all the time 24 7. it's closing deals at
9 00 p.m
at 6 a lot of work yeah a lot of hours a
lot of work a lot of accessibility so
not trying to dissuade you i'm saying
you have a higher probability of being
in the real estate business five years
from today if you lay a really
cash strong foundation with an emergency
fund and your other cash up front before
you go in
it's going to help you with your success
probability on this because you do have
probably a tough fight
i do think you should do it and i do
think you can do it
but i think it's going to be tough i
yeah
i just have worked with a good real
estate real estate folks and not good
ones man and it's such a it's such a
difference
it's incredible yeah it is and um and
they're everywhere
yeah i mean there's you know it is truly
the pareto principle
eighty percent of the business is done
by twenty percent of people in the
business really
yeah and you take that that eighty
percent and it's another twenty eighty
twenty
again down to where you know one point
six percent are doing
you know the vast majority of the
transactions it's crazy
i mean so you've got one real estate
agent's doing 400 transactions a year
another one does one transaction a year
is it just because it's a side gig or
they just don't hustle or
well no some people just reach another
level in their career they're another
level
in the octane that they're operating off
of and you know the protein just
drips off their eyelids you know and
it's just uh and then
uh you know and everything comes
together you know and they some build
teams to do it with and everything else
so
our elps we work with all the time you
know so we're looking at these high
octane people and
it's amazing you know uh
what can be done so i don't ever want to
be a dream killer
no but also don't want a dream turned
into a nightmare that's especially the
little one
yeah there you go hey jessica good luck
with it darling thank you for calling in
let us know how it works out i'd love to
hear from you when you're big time
successful real estate agent
john good show thank you sir dr john
deloney
and that puts this hour of the ramsey
show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life
let them know about the ramsey call of
the day podcast
it's a quick hit of advice about life
and money in
under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast
wherever you listen to podcasts
you